POMPOSITY, SMUGNESS, AND
GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY FROM NEW YORK NOW.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
PRESIDENT TRUMP WRAPPED UP
ANOTHER MASSIVE RALLY, YEP, THE
RALLIES ARE BACK.
LOOK AT THIS VIDEO FROM DAN’S
GIVE YOU KNOW.
DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
CAN EVER GET CROWDS THE SIZE?
KEEP WATCHING, KEEP LOOKING AT
THE VIDEO.
LOOK AT IT, BECAUSE WHAT YOU
SEE, THAT IS THE OVERFLOW CROWD.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T
FIT IN THE MASSIVE RALLY SPACE
IN FREELAND, MICHIGAN, TONIGHT.
SUPPORTERS LINING UP AROUND THE
BLOCK AND DOWN THE STREET.
WE WILL SHOW IT ALL.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, SOME WERE
WAITING IN LINE FOR MORE THAN
24 HOURS.
WE’VE GOT THE HIGHLIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ON FIRE
TONIGHT.
ALONG WITH, ALSO TONIGHT, A FULL
REPORT, OUR 2020 ELECTION
CORRESPONDENT, LAWRENCE JONES.
HE IS ON THE GROUND.
HE WAS AT THE RALLY TONIGHT.
ALSO, WE ARE GOING TO BRING YOU
BREAKING NEWS FROM THE DURHAM
PROBE.
THIS IS HUGE.
MUELLER’S TEAM, LED BY, OF
COURSE, HIS HIT MAN,
ANDREW WEISSMANN, THE PITBULL,
CAUGHT IN A MASSIVE COVER-UP,
JUST LIKE HILLARY CLINTON,
ALMOST ALL OF THEM, GUESS WHAT,
THEY WIPED THEIR PHONES CLEAN.
HMM, IS THAT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE BY TEAM MUELLER?
WE WILL INVESTIGATE.
AND ARE MORE CHARGE ON THE WAY?
FIRST, WE START WITH ANOTHER
BLATANT LIE FROM THE EVER
FORGETFUL JOE BIDEN.
JOE ACTUALLY WANTS AMERICANS,
YEAR, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, TO
BELIEVE THAT HE CAN BEAT
COVID-19, BUT ONLY IF YOU ELECT
HIM.
IF YOUR MEMBERS WHAT IT IS IN
NOVEMBER, DECEMBER, JANUARY.
HE CLAIMS HE SOUNDED THE ALARM
EARLY ON ABOUT THE DEADLY VIRUS
AND THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
EVERYTHING WRONG, OKAY, JOE IS
LYING, JUST LIKE HIS FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB, AND WELL, MOST
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS THESE DAYS.
JOE BIDEN IS LIVING AND
ALTERNATIVE REALITY.
ONCE AGAIN, HERE ARE THE FACTS
THAT THE HATE-TRUMP MEDIA MOB
WILL NEVER GIVE YOU.
WE WILL DO THEIR JOB FOR THEM.
IN LATE JANUARY, JUST DAYS
BEFORE, THE PRESIDENT ISSUED
WHAT WAS THE UNPRECEDENTED CHINA
TRAVEL BAN, FIRST QUARANTINE IN
50 YEARS, TEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST IDENTIFIED CASE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WELL, BIDEN’S TOP ADVISOR, HIS
NAME IS RON CLAIM, HE WAS
ACTUALLY PRAISING CHINA’S
TRANSPARENCY.
HUH >> President Trump:
WATCH THIS.
>> CHINA HAS BEEN MORE
TRANSPARENT AND CANDID THAN IT
HAS DURING PAST OUTBREAKS,
THOUGH STILL THERE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND CANDOR.
>> Sean: OKAY, THE SAME CHINA
WHERE ZERO EXPERIENCED HUNTER
BIDEN, $1.5 BILLION DEAL, NOT
DEUTSCHE BANK, NOT
GOLDMAN SACHS, NOT
CHASE, NO, THAT WOULD BE
JOE BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN.
QUID PRO QUO SUCKING UP TO
HUNTER.
PETER SCHWEIZER IT HAS
IDENTIFIED THIS IN DETAIL.
AND SO WILL, ON JANUARY 28TH, 3
DAYS BEFORE THE THE PRESIDENTS
TRAVEL BAN, SEVEN DAYS BEFORE
THE FIRST IDENTIFIED CASE,
THIS SAME BIDEN HEALTH ADVISOR
SAID HE OPPOSED THE TRAVEL BAN.
IT WAS PREMATURE.
BUT THEY WERE ON TOP OF IT.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SAID.
WATCH.
>> WOULD YOU BAN CHINESE
TRAVELERS FROM ARRIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I WOULDN’T.
I THINK THAT IS PREMATURE.
I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
EXCHANGE, VERY IMPORTANT FOR
TRADE AND TOURISM, AND THE VERY,
VERY FEW OF THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
IT.
WHAT’S MORE, SINCE THIS VIRUS
BROKE OUT, A QUARTER MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE COME FROM CHINA, SO
THEY ARE ALREADY HERE.
>> Sean: ONE DAY BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTS TRAVEL BAN,
JANUARY 30TH, TOP BIDEN HEALTH
OFFICIAL DR. ZEKE EMANUEL SAID
EVERYONE NEEDED TO STOP
PANICKING, STOP BEING
HYSTERICAL.
THEN, ON FEBRUARY 1ST, THAT IS
THE DAY AFTER TRAVEL BAN WAS
IMPLEMENTED, TEN DAYS THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE OF CORONA, JOE
HIMSELF TWEETED OUT THAT THE
TRAVEL BAN WAS HYSTERICAL,
XENOPHOBIA, AND FEARMONGERING.
ON FEBRUARY 13TH, TOP BIDEN
ADVISOR KLAIN TWEETED THAT WE
ARE EXPERIENCING A FEAR
EPIDEMIC, NOT A COVID-19
EPIDEMIC.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF CALLED THE
AGGRESSIVE COVID-19 RESPONSE,
THE TRAVEL BAN, FIRST QUARANTINE
IN OVER 50 YEARS, HYSTERICAL,
XENOPHOBIA, FEARMONGERING, ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS, AS LATE AS
MARCH THE 18TH.
MEANWHILE, JOE BIDEN WAS STILL
HOLDING INDOOR RALLIES IN THE
MONTH OF MARCH, AND HE WAS
DOLING OUT HIS WORLD FAMOUS
CREEPY HUGS, REMEMBER THOSE?
HE WASN’T TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL
DISTANCING, HE WASN’T WEARING A
MASK, HE WASN’T COORDINATING AN
AGGRESSIVE USE OF THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT PLAN OR SOURCING
EE.
HE WAS AGAINST THE TRAVEL BAN
COME AGAINST THE QUARANTINE COME
AGAINST THE SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL
BAN.
NOW, THAT LIKELY SAVED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS FROM
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS, AND GOD
KNOWS HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS FROM DYING.
AND BY THE WAY, HE DIDN’T GET TO
THAT UNTIL APRIL.
GET THIS, BIDEN’S PRESS
SECRETARY, NOW, LIKE BIDEN, MY
INCOME UP ATTENDING THE EVER
FORGETFUL JOE WAS ALWAYS IN FAVO
THAT IS CALLED A LIE.
THE BAN JOE CALLED MULTIPLE
TIMES, INCLUDING LATE MARCH,
HYSTERICAL, XENOPHOBIC
FEARMONGERING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU ARE SAYING JOE BIDEN WAS
FORECLOSING DOWN TO TRAVEL FROM
CHINA WHEN THE PRESIDENT DID IT?
>> JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN CONTINUED,
THE FACT-CHECKED -- HE WAS
AGAINST THAT TRAVEL BAN --
>> HE WAS FOR A?
>> JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN CLEAR
ABOUT THIS, I CAN SEND YOU THE
FACT-CHECKED IF THEY ARE
HELPFUL, THIS HAS BEEN
FACT-CHECKED INTO OBLIVION.
>> I’M JUST ASKING THE QUESTION,
YOU ARE SAYING YES, HE WAS FOR
THE CHINA TRAVEL BAN WHEN THE
PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED IT 48
HOURS AFTER RECEIVING THAT
BRIEFING?
>> THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THE
TRAVEL BAN --
>> YES OR NO.
>> BRET, I KNOW YOU LIKE TO CITE
THE TRAVEL BAN --
>> NO, THE PRESIDENT DOES,
THAT’S WHY I AM BRINGING IT UP.
>> BRET, HOLD ON, AN IMPORTANT
THING IN OVER THE TRAVEL BAN IS
EVEN AFTER THE PRESIDENT
IMPLEMENTED THAT TRAVEL BAN, OR
SAYS HE IMPLEMENT IT, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CAME IN OR
OUT --
>> I’M GOING TO TAKE YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO ANSWER MY QUESTION, YOU
ARE GOING TO SEND ME SOME FACT
CHECKS.
>> Sean: BRET BAIER HAS THE
PATIENCE OF JOB HERE, BECAUSE HE
IS LYING, AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
IT.
WHEN OTHER WORDS, JOE BIDEN DID
EVERYTHING WRONG, BUT NOW HE IS
GOING TO LIE ABOUT IT AND HOPE
THAT YOU WILL ALL FORGET WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED.
I LOVE THE WOODWARD HYSTERIA,
BUT BOB WOODWARD’S BOOK, YEAH,
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WANTED TO
CALM FEARS IN AMERICA, WHAT DO
WE HAVE TO FEAR BUT FEAR ITSELF,
FDR SAID AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
GREAT DEPRESSION, WORLD WAR II,
REMEMBER THOSE TOUGH DAYS?
CHURCHILL, YOU KNOW, THE BOMBING
OF BRITAIN, MARCHING WITH THE
PEOPLE OF BRITAIN, WAS HE
TALKING -- GET THEM IN THE HILLS
AND EVERYWHERE, BLOOD, TEARS,
SWEAT, THAT IS WHAT LEADERS DO.
FIVE IN THE SAYING, NO, THIS IS
HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBIA
FEARMONGERING.
HE ON OFFERED NO SOLUTIONS,
NOTHING NEW FOR BIDEN AND HIS
TEAM TO LIE, AND BY THE WAY,
IMAGINE IF BRET BAIER WAS
ACTUALLY CAUTIONING JOE BIDEN
THERE.
THAT WOULD BE TV PAPER VIEW.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, HE LIES
ABOUT THAT, "REALLOCATION" HE
CALLS THAT.
FRACKING?
AGAINST IT COME AGAINST IT, BUT
NO, I WAS ALWAYS FOR.
PROTEST?
NO, THEY ARE PEACEFUL, TO WELL,
IT IS SHOWING UP BADLY IN THE
POLLS.
NATIONAL MASK MANDATE?
JOE BIDEN SAID I DON’T WANT
THAT, EITHER.
OKAY, HE LIES ABOUT PRETTY MUCH
EVERY POSITION HE HAS EVER
TAKEN, ONLY IF IT HELPS THEM
POLITICALLY.
ONLY IF THE POLLS AND FOCUS
GROUPS TELL HIM WHAT TO SAY,
LIKE DON LEMON ADVISED HIM TO
LISTEN TO.
BUT HERE IS WHAT IS MORE
CONCERNING.
JOE BIDEN IS ACTUALLY, REALLY
WEAK.
AND FRAIL.
AND IT DOESN’T SEEM MENTALLY
ALERT OR ON TOP OF HIS GAME,
DOESN’T SEEM TO HAVE A LOT OF,
WELL, LET’S SAY MENTAL ACUITY.
JUST LISTEN TO BIDEN’S TOP
ADVISOR, THE GUY YOU JUST HEARD
FROM, RON KLAIN, SAYING THE
BIDEN-OBAMA RESPONSE, LISTEN TO
WHAT THEY ADMITTED ABOUT THEIR
RESPONSE TO THE H1N1 VIRUS, NOT
THE AND 1H1 VIRUS, AS BIDEN
CALLS IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WASN’T INVOLVED DIRECTLY IN
THE H1N1 RESPONSE, BUT I LIVE
THROUGH IT AS A WHITE HOUSE
STAFFER, AND WHAT I WILL SAY
ABOUT IT IS A BUNCH OF
REALLY TALENTED, REALLY GREAT
PEOPLE WORKING ON IT, AND WE DID
EVERY POSSIBLE THING WRONG, AND
YOU KNOW, 60 MILLION AMERICANS
GOT H1N1 H1N1 IN THAT PERIOD OF
AND IT IS PURELY A FORTUITY THIS
ISN’T ONE OF THE GREAT MASS
CASUALTY EVENTS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
US DOING ANYTHING RIGHT, I JUST
HAD TO DO WITH LUCK.
>> Sean: HE DID EVERYTHING
WRONG, AND THEY DIDN’T PREPARE F
PANDEMIC.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, 50 YEARS IN THE
SWAMP, JOE BIDEN IS NOW MORE
INCOMPETENT THAN EVER.
NOBODY -- OUR OWN
LAWRENCE JONES, 2020
CORRESPONDENT ON THE GROUND, AND
HE HAS EVER INTERVIEWED, HAS
EVER BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY A
SINGLE COMPLIMENT IN 50 YEARS OF
JOE BIDEN IN THE SWAMP.
THAT HAS MADE LIFE BETTER FOR
YOU, THE MEGAN PEOPLE.
I COULD SPEND THE SHOW TALKING
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PROMISES
MADE, PROMISES KEPT,
UNEMPLOYMENT, BUILDING THE LAW,
ORIGINALISTS ON THE
SUPREME COURT, NEW TRADE DEALS,
PULLING OUT OF PROTRACTED WARS,
DEFEATING THE CALIPHATE,
SOLEIMANI, AL BAGHDADI, AL QAEDA
LEADERS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
BIDEN MIGHT AGAIN THIS WEEK,
NEARLY 6200 U.S. MILITARY
MEMBERS DIED FROM CORONA.
WELL, HE IS WRONG AGAIN.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXACTLY SEVEN
MILITARY DEATHS FROM COVID-19.
NOT NEARLY 6200.
WITHOUT A TELEPROMPTER, THE EVER
FORGETFUL JOE CAN BARELY
COMMUNICATE.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A FEW
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT BIDEN’S,
WELL, PRECIOUS TELEPROMPTER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> AS WE CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE-BASED APPROACH TO
PROTECT OUR PEOPLE AND VANQUISH
THE VIRUS, JOE BIDEN CONTINUES
TO USE THE PANDEMIC FOR
POLITICAL AGAIN.
HE IS READING OFF A
TELEPROMPTER.
I’M NOT ALLOWED TO USE A
WHY IS THAT?
THEY ASK QUESTIONS, AND HE
STARTS READING THE TELEPROMPTER.
HE SAYS "MOVIE TELEPROMPTER
LITTLE BIT CLOSER, PLEASE."
I DON’T KNOW, I THINK IF I DID
THAT, I WOULD BE IN BIG TROUBLE,
THAT WOULD BE THE STORY OF THE
YEAR.
>> Sean: TELEPROMPTER, CAN YOU
MOVE IT DOWN?
THE TELEPROMPTER -- I HAVE TO
READ THE ANSWER.
THE PRESIDENT’S RIGHT.
AND GET THIS, APPARENTLY BIDEN’S
TELEPROMPTER IS NOT JUST HIS
SPEECHES, IT LOOKS AN AWFUL LOT
LIKE HE IS USING IT TO ANSWER
SUPPOSEDLY UNSCRIPTED QUESTIONS.
JUST LISTEN TO BIDEN’S PRESS
SECRETARY FROM EARLIER TODAY.
THIS IS ANOTHER GREAT MOMENT.
>> HAS JOE BIDEN EVER USED A
TELEPROMPTER DURING LOCAL
INTERVIEWS OR TO ANSWER Q&A WITH
SUPPORTERS?
>> BRET, WE ARE NOT GOING TO --
THIS IS STRAIGHT FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> YEAH, THEY ARE USING IT.
>> WHAT IT DOES, BRET, IS IT IS
TRYING TO DISTRACT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE --
>> THEY TALK ABOUT IT EVERY DAY,
CAN YOU SAY YES OR NO?
BRET, BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE A
COHERENT --
>> YOU DIDN’T ANSWER, YES OR
NO --
>> BRET, THEY TALK ABOUT IT
EVERY DAY BECAUSE THEY DON’T
HAVE A COHERENT ARGUMENT FOR WHY
DONALD TRUMP --
>> BUT YOU CAN’T ANSWER THE
QUESTION --
>> BRET, I AM NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO CHANNEL
THEIR QUESTIONS THROUGH FOX NEWS
AND GET ME TO ANSWER THAT.
>> Sean: DOES HE USE THE
TELEPROMPTER TO ANSWER A
QUESTION, YES OR NO?
SIMPLE QUESTION.
THAT IS WHAT YOU CALL AN EVASIVE
NONANSWER, BECAUSE HE WOULD HAVE
TO LIE AGAIN.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW WHAT HIS
CAMPAIGN IS TRYING TO LIMIT HIS
EXTEMPORANEOUS COMMENTS.
JUST LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
WEDNESDAY.
JOE HAD TO GO OFF SCRIPT, HE HAD
A LITTLE TROUBLE.
>> I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL.
I CARRY WITH ME -- I DON’T HAVE
IT, I GAVE IT TO MY STAFF -- BUT
I CARRY WITH ME, IN MY POCKET,
A -- DO I HAVE THAT AROUND?
WHERE IS -- I GAVE IT -- ANYWAY.
I CARRY A SCHEDULE IN MY POCKET.
>> Sean: WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS
TO BE SELF EVIDENT, ALL MEN ARE
CREATED -- THING, THING, YOU
KNOW.
COME ON, MAN.
COME ON, YOU A JUNKIE?
IT GETS WORSE.
AT A DIFFERENT EVENT, WEDNESDAY,
BIDEN COULDN’T REMEMBER WHAT
TAXES HE WANTS TO RAISE, HE WAS
TRILLIONS, BUT DOESN’T REMEMBER,
WHICH ONES, WHICHEVER THEY PUT
IN FRONT OF ME, I WILL SIGN IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU CHANGE THE TAX RATE
FROM 38% TO 21%, 38%, 36%, 28%.
THAT’S WHAT WE START TO TRY TO
DO.
IT WENT DOWN TO 21%.
>> Sean: THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE
AN INFORMATION CRISIS IN THE
COUNTRY, THIS IS SERIOUS, WE
DON’T HAVE ANY REAL JOURNALISTS,
FAKE NEWS CNN, MSDNC, IF ANY OF
NEWSPAPERS, EDWARD NETWORKS,
NBC, STATE RUN -- IF IT WAS
DONALD TRUMP, I PROMISE IT WOULD
STORY.
INSTEAD, "WASHINGTON POST," MORE
FOCUSED ON PRAISING, LE HARRIS
ON HER SHOE CHOICE.
MEANWHILE, MAJOR NETWORKS
DEVOTED MINUTES TO SMEARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT NOT HIS
PEACE PRIZE NOMINATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS ON FIRE,
HE IS ON OFFENSE TONIGHT, DID
SOMETHING JOE BIDEN SIBLEY
CANNOT DO, ACTUALLY HOLD A REAL
RALLY, THE LIBERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT
DELIVER ASPEECH IN FRONT OF A MA
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION IN THE HISTORY OUR
COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN DEVOTED HIS CAREER TO
OFF SHORING MICHIGAN’S JOBS,
OUTSOURCING --
BIDEN SUPPORTED EVERY
DISASTROUS, GLOBAL SELLOUT FOR
OVER HALF A CENTURY, INCLUDING
NAFTA, CHINA, AND TPE, YOU KNOW
THAT.
JOE BIDEN SURRENDERED YOUR JOBS
TO CHINA, AND HE WANTS TO
SURRENDER OUR COUNTRY TO THE
VIOLENT, LEFT-WING MOB, AND YOU
ARE SEEING THAT EVERY NIGHT.
IF BIDEN WINS, CHINA WINS.
IF BIDEN WINS, THE MOB WINS.
IF BIDEN WINS, THE RIOTERS,
ANARCHISTS, ARSONISTS, AND FLAG
BURNERS WIN.
BUT I WOULDN’T WORRY ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE HE’S NOT WINNING, I
DON’T THINK HE’S WINNING.
>> Sean: IT’S ALL ON THE
BALLOT.
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
IN 24 DAYS.
BIDEN IS HOLDING VIRTUAL Q&A
SESSIONS ON INSTAGRAM.